mais voilà aujourd'hui pour vous parler
de cette petite bête là elle est déjà
senti quelque temps c'est le son premier
smartphone milieu de gamme de google
c'est le pixel 3 à ixelles pas si vous
avez suivi je pense peut-être peut-être
l'année dernière google a fait son
arrivée en france avec les google pixels
3 pixels 3xl et ce pixel trois faits a
été franchement pas terrible avec une
énorme encoches n'est pas très très beau
là ils ont modifié un petit peu
l'histoire d'un point de vue design en
nous proposant un grand smartphone qui
ressemble en réalité aux pixels trois
enfants n'a plus grands ils n'ont pas
non plus révolutionner l'histoire on va
se faire un petit tour de ce pic salle 3
à ixelles je vais vous montrer un peu ce
que j'ai pu faire en photo parce que
c'est vraiment le gros point fort des
smartphones et au final on va se poser
la question est ce que cette bête là il
faut l'acheter est ce qu'elle est
intéressante vu son positionnement vu
l'arrivée en tout cas de google sur le
milieu de gamme et ce qui l'est bien oui
non comme en bref go
[Musique]
autant se le dire tout de suite
moi j'aime bien ce smartphone parce que
je le trouve performant vraiment
performant au niveau de la photo il ya
un bon équilibre entre la puissance
qu'elle était photo qui est vraiment
excellente
dans ce segment par aucun truc qui me
fait dire que ce smartphone la face
devant moi c'est le design on est quand
même sur un design qui est relativement
classique old school et qui est pas du
tout dans ce qui se fait aujourd'hui en
2019 alors c'est vrai que toutes les
personnes qui font partie du milieu de
la tec dans le domaine des smartphones
en tout cas se dire on en attend ce
smartphone il vraiment bien en termes de
photos vu ce qu'il est capable de faire
vu le segment pris les autres le font
pas c'est une évidence mais moi je suis
un consommateur aussi et je me dis que
lorsque je vais aller acheter un produit
je vais avant tout première chose au
regard des l'esthétique avant de me dire
ok c'est le top de la photo mais si je
veux le top de la photo je suis pas sûr
d'aller sur un smartphone néanmoins il a
beau être au top en photographie pour
moi la copie de google est pas bonne là
dessus parce que vous avez quand même un
truc qui freine trop trop trop trop trop
school parce que ces grandes bandes
hurla est là pour moi aujourd'hui c'est
malheureusement plus du tout actuelle je
ne comprends pas le positionnement
google l'année dernière on s'est dit
maintenant google arrive dans votre
carrière
on arrive en france on va dans des pays
dans lequel on n'était pas jusqu'à
présent le pic ces deux n'était pas
sorti si le pic ces trois on arrive avec
celle trois pics à 3 xl et on s'en fiche
un petit peu parce que nous on est
google on a une force de frappe
on a le logiciel d'arrière qui est
énorme et en photos fait des choses que
personne ne fait c'est une certitude
mais ça c'est du point de vue de google
de l'ingénieur du point de vue
consommateur formant nie pas et c'est
vraiment la grosse erreur qu'a fait
google l'année dernière ils ont corrigé
le problème de l'encoche là dessus mais
on ne soit pas solutionner le problème
j'attends de voir ce qui va avec le
pixel par pixel 4xl hommage octobre 2019
ainsi pendant qu'ils soient vraiment
cette fois-ci corriger cette
problématique de design parce que ça
pour moi voilà c'est ce smartphone il
peut pas se vendre comme ça c'est
vraiment dommage parce que c'est
vraiment un excellent smartphone il a
plein de points positifs et une fois de
plus vu le positionnement tarifaire
pouvoir c'est la première fois que
google arrive dans le milieu de gamme
c'est vraiment un choix de produits
voilà à l'intérieur après tout est ce
qu'on dit pas que la beauté est à
l'intérieur
si mais est ce que ça vaut aussi pour
les smartphones ce qui est question
on sort rapide tour du propriétaire le
design sous les 10 il n'y a rien de bien
bien révolutionnaire vous
un haut parleur que si tu es là une
caméra là ici en bail absolument rien
alors sur un pixel 3 pixels 3xl vous
aviez ici un petit haut parleur ce qui
nous permettait d'avoir ce que vous ne
mettiez en façade et la conque ou sade
est vraiment un sens deux hauts parleurs
en façade et là vous aviez vraiment un
son qui était assez directionnelle là le
haut parleur en bas il est situé là je
pense pour une question de coût de
fabrication sont dégoûtés qu'elle
beaucoup moins cher mais on y
pareillement qualité sonore bon ça je
m'excuse à quelques instants bouton pour
l'allumer bouton pour régler le volume
lorsque vous le presser sur les côtés ça
vous déclenché de l'assistant c'est
plutôt sympathique
la com vous lisez vous avez votre haut
parleurs de l'usbc petit micron qui
cache et les dessous ici vous avez le
tir aux cartes sim
l'arrivée ici de la prise jack ça c'est
plutôt pas mal pour tous ceux qui
veulent écouter encore casque vous avez
si votre micro pour la réduction de
bruit le dos tout en plastique bien
évidemment ici pas de dons envers donc
pas de recharge à induction on a
néanmoins côté matt qui prend quand même
des petites traces mais c'est quand même
moins que sur le côté brillant pour sont
un petit peu deux aspects c'est assez
rigolo soit mais au smartphone être un
petit peu plus léger il fait 167 g sadr
a passé le grand modèle il s'attend mais
plutôt bien une main lui 95 digital qui
est très rapide très réactif
donc ça ça fonctionne parfaitement bien
fait d'ailleurs ce smartphone vous
invite à venir protéger un faux pas
l'abîmer
ce que je veux qu'on fait c'est de
prendre des coques trilogie de l'ag
l'école pour google pixels 3g rien pour
le 3 xl mais vous trouverez les coques
son site de rhinau chiffres qui sont
sympas on a plein de comm du 40 vous
invite à aller faire un tour sur leur
site d'ailleurs si ça vous intéresse
vous avez un code promo avec le code
monsieur groupe vous verrez garder
j'aime bien les deux au carbone comme sa
cousine moi tout ça sympa je vous invite
à l'islam qui voulait tout ça s'anticipe
de rhinau chine avec le code réduction
c'est en bas c'est dans la description
d'un écran de 6,4 poussée du pays aux
legs 2160 par 1080 pixels ratio 18/9
c'est cool ça marche bien à quatre
sortes de pixels par pouce c'est un
smartphone qui marche très bien lorsque
vous le mettez deux heures lorsqu'un du
soleil il est cool
il ya un beau contraste et moi j'ai un
problème de connexion tallec mais mise à
part ça c'est vrai qu'il est quand même
plutôt bien comme je les ai vus comme
des audio vous avez offert leur fille
ella jones a rapporté mme en immersion
le deuxième haut parleurs qui est ici
parce qu'on ait une différence de
qualité de son grâce peut-être parce que
c'est plus directif là et là un petit
peu moins c'est vrai que vu les
smartphones le chrono ce prix là vous
gueulez pas des rares à le faire donc
pas l'absolu ce avec les croyances et
joe est plutôt bien c'est vrai que
globalement l'expérience pour le
multimédia pour le gaming vachement
agréable malgré le
le design fait plus soit à gg l'écran
une bonne qualité il est bien ce dilemme
l'extérieur ça marche parfaitement bien
la qualité audio est vraiment bien le
fait d'avoir les haut parleurs stéréo
s'écoule la prise jack c'est très bien
il ya en plus un spectre qui est
vraiment très bien si vous avez un bon
casque profiterait d'une qualité qui est
vraiment très sympa que ça marche bien
ce smartphone si vous voulez l'acheter
pour profiter d'un bon écran pour le
gaming pour visionner des vidéos youtube
netflix que vous voulez mais non hd ça
marche parfaitement bien et ça c'est
vraiment appréciable après ce qu il faut
bien savoir si on laisse faire un modèle
milieu de gamme avec un processeur
milieu de gamme c'est un snapdragon 670
de paul comme il ya 4 gigas de ram 64 et
le stockage non extensible soyez
tranquilles on a effectivement moins de
performance avec le pixel 3 et pixel 3xl
néanmoins pour lui acheter un pour tout
ce que vous allez pouvoir en faire ça
marche parfaitement bien vous serez
vraiment tranquille donc je vous dis
pour y faire des jeux même joue un
peuple j à ce que vous voulez vous aura
fallu mans aucun problème on tombe sur
un os 100% google android 9 paille qui
marchent merveilleusement bien qu'ils
aient complètement optimisé qui marche
bien qui est pratique c'est sympa ça
c'est un gros point fort pour ce
smartphone parce qu'il est complètement
optimisé j'avais déjà beaucoup aimé sur
le pixel 3 pixels 3xl là avec le 3 à 6,3
à ixelles c'est la même chose
l'expérience est vraiment bien cerveau
et android et ce point de vue là non
plus ne serait absolument pas déçu
la durabilité de la batterie est très
bonne vous pouvez garder deux jours ça
dépend bien sûr une faculté de vos
usages mais nous n'osons vous êtes
vraiment bien avec une batterie de 3700
milliards alors sur le 3 à ixelles aux
grands modèles ont une plus grosse
batterie sur trois est un petit peu
moins mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu de
beaux efforts faits par rapport au 3xl
qui sorti fin d'année dernière la
longévité est meilleur et ça c'était un
point j'avais vraiment regretté sur le
pixel 3 pas le xml et à un petit peu
meilleure mais le pixel 3 pour moi vous
tenez une journée et des foyers encore
ça c'était vraiment le gros gros gros
problème ce smartphone avec le 3 à
ixelles vous arrivez à deux journées si
vous êtes à la cool
sinon une journée mais vous êtes
vraiment tranquille comme ça plutôt bien
plus de la recharge rapide 18 watts et
pas la recharge la plus rapide du monde
mais dans la plus que mais plutôt pas
mal mais gros focus sur ce smartphone il
se fait pas là il se fait pas sur la
batterie c'est pas sur la performance et
surtout sur la partie photo c'est un an
gros point fort goût
l'année dernière avec un seul mobile
photo ils font beaucoup mieux que
beaucoup de smartphones qui ont deux à
trois modules photos tandis que ce n'est
pas le nombre qui fait la qualité est là
ils ont vraiment continuer dans ce sens
là avec un capteur principal arrière de
12,2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.8 alors
vous avez une techno qui est vraiment
maîtrisé par google sa techno du pixel
qui marche parfaitement bien et surtout
derrière vous avez une partie logicielle
qui est absolument incroyable avec de
l'intelligence artificielle qui va
vraiment comprendre les photos avec une
bague ne l'était toujours enrichie donc
des photos qui sont toujours meilleures
optimisée et ça c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment top
à l'avant là vous avez une caméra de 8
mégapixels ouverture de f 2.0
bon vous pouvez filmer l'arrière goethe
en 4k à 30fps pas trop l'intérêt pour
aller jusqu'en 1080p à 120 fps plutôt
pas mal bon c'est un smartphone qui est
vraiment excellent en termes de photos
il fera moins de choses que ce que vous
pouvez faire avec le pixel 3 et 3 xl
c'est normal que quand même beaucoup
moins cher voulu faire des économies à
un moment ou à un autre parce que bon on
pouvait pas sortir
la smart phones beaucoup moins cher avec
elle toute l'année le techno mais par
contre le rendu reste quand même au
dessus du panier pour tout dans cette
positionnement à moins de 500 euros
c'est vrai que le rendu au niveau de la
photo est vraiment top regarder le ciel
le bleu du ciel comme il est prononcé
les nuages qui ressorte bien vous avez
tous les ombres même les ombres au
niveau des boutons sont vraiment hyper
juste les ordres au niveau du sol n'y a
absolument rien de cramer tout est
optimiste ce soit à l'arrière que ce
soit à l'avant on a une photo qui est
parfaite qui est parfaitement maîtrisé
vers la savait qu'on en plein jour on a
un soleil de plomb
mais il ya vraiment un rendu qui est
vraiment hyper hyper propres là c'est
pareil ans et le hellfest gilles était
ce week end c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
plein de photos la regarder ce pas le
ciel sont tous c'est vraiment incroyable
comme on voit les nuages mois toutes les
traîner dans ciel on va les traces les
ondes sont très justes de tous les côtés
c'est vraiment parfait là c'est pareil
c'est extrêmement parfait c'est très
beau l'appareil au nez sur le un concert
du groupe eagles of death metal pour une
plage dynamique qui complètement dingue
on a un rendu qui est hyper hyper
qualitatif par contre dès qu'on vient
zoomer dedans c'est tout de suite pas
terrible du tout c'est franchement très
mauvais on a du bruit du pixel de
partout va c'est pas du tout faits pour
ça et là voyez même le mode portrait de
groupe avec la caméra de celle fit
marche parfaitement bien alors il ya des
endroits où c'est pas extrêmement par
février détourage le tour des cheveux
un petit peu de mal là au niveau de la
casquette des cheveux mais pour voir à
la caméra par contre c'est pareil il
n'ya pas des tours il a pas reconnu
comme un visage donc c'est pour ça qu'il
est par les deux tours est vraiment venu
faire le tour voyez là ici et là une
photo qui est prise avec le module
arrière c'est pas regarder extrêmement
juste super qualité
là on est sur un concert du groupe kiss
je vois quand même les têtes des gens
qui sont éclairés voyez derrière la
petite temps classé le merchandising des
artistes je l'avais dit c'est qu'ils
regardaient las ce qui est dingue on
voit bien toutes les têtes qui sont
éclairés juste au bout toujours elle
fait cette photo nuit le public là sur
le devant qu'on voit bien derrière celle
les lance-flammes nous lance du feu donc
là c'était un petit peu plus difficile
c'est les conditions un peu
particulières honnêtement vous avez
quand même la fumée qu'on voit bien
qu'il est bien dessine en ciel et la
regarder on voit bien l'arrière quand on
vient où mais en arrière-plan ici on
voit bien toutes les constructions qui
sont faites on voit bien la fumée dans
le ciel qui est assez juste ici c'est
forcément plus difficile parce que on
est en tout petit cela c'est vraiment
très impressionnant au niveau du du ciel
non un soleil d'été qui est vraiment
absolument incroyable la regarder sur le
bonheur je vous ai quand même tous les
détails pouvoir vous avez le soleil en
pleine face vous avez tous les détails
qui sont présents ici sur la sculpture
on voit bien les détails avec le ciel
rien est cramé c'est hyper
impressionnant la façon d'élever ses la
voyez ça monte vraiment toute la force
et la puissance parce que on ferait
qu'un autre smartphone on n'aurait pas
les détails là de la sculpture les
détails de partout avec le ciel qui est
pas cramé avec même les gouttes d'eau en
bas le rendu de cette photo est vraiment
impressionnant ça me manque vraiment
tout cas ce que sait faire google d'un
point de vue logiciel là vous avez la
fontaine dans le carré vip du hellfest
petite fontaine effet centre s arrêter
je travaillais mêmes conditions voit
bien les gouttes en bas là qu'ils sont
en train de de couler on voit bien le
ciel le rendu tout est très juste on
voit tout rien est cramé c'est vraiment
vraiment top
google maîtrise vraiment sa copie en
terme de photos et c'est vraiment le
gros gros gros gros point fort de ce
smartphone si vous voulez un smartphone
d'un milieu de gamme à moins de 500
euros avec un grand écran tout terrain
avec une bonne qualité audio celui là et
hop il va falloir oublier
l'esthétique mais comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure je ne dit on pas que la
beauté réel est à l'intérieur là c'est
clairement le cas le smartphone est bien
s'il vous intéresse les disponible au
tarif de doute là dessus je n'ai pas
appris par coeur 479 euros si le botia
un lien ma dans la description vous
maintenant de me dire ce que vous en
pensez
on va on commenté à comment nous trouver
sur google fixé trois à ixelles le grand
modèle et je vous dis une fois de plus
on en reparlera en bonne novembre pas de
celui là mais du googleplex n 4 il
devrait y avoir un truc vraiment
intéressant google a fait le choix de m
plusieurs modules photo 3d photo me
semble-t-il rien j'en ai déjà parlé dans
une précédente vidéo mais ça c'est vrai
que ça va être vachement cool très
intéressant et ça a été confirmé un ceux
qui l'ont confirmé donc les on en est
sûr et certain
alors j'imagine même pas le travail près
tu mens logiciel qu'il va y avoir
derrière avec plus clairement du photo
je pense que là ça à mettre une claque
sévère à tout le monde
j'attends vraiment de voir ça j'espère
j'espère en tout cas qu'il vont revoir
leur copie
du point de vue design si google arrive
avec un design hyper sexy avec un
smartphone hyper performant avec un
sparring 11 855 avec de la ram avec du
stockage avec un dos en verre de la rose
induction une recharge rapide avec une
grosse batterie parce que bien pour une
fois sur ce modèle là en tout cas avec
plusieurs mordus photo il pourrait il
pourrait faire mal on suit ça normal à
demain